Birdman Oh fighter of the Batman Birdman
so Birdman is a movie starring Michael
Keaton want to say it's starring Michael
Keaton playing Michael Keaton because
this dude in this movies probably it's
Michael Keaton Michael Keaton plays an
actor who used to be a superhero back in
the day and then in 1992 which is the
year Batman Returns came out he stopped
being a superhero because he wanted to
focus on acting he wanted to be real and
now we follow him around as he's trying
to get this play together on Broadway
and this play is having a hundred and
fifty problems and Edward Norton comes
into it and it's not even the impressive
part the fact that Michael Keaton and
Edward Norton completely kill it in this
movie that's not even where I was like
holy early on in the movie is like
the second scene in the movie and I was
just like wait is this still one shot
this movie is all film to look like it
is all one shot it's not there are
transitions in the movie you can see
where the transitions could be but oh my
god it feels like the opening shot of
Goodfellas for the entire movie this is
actually my importantly original and
very revolutionary if anyone asked me if
a movie like that could happen I'd be
like absolutely not actually now after I
saw it and it does work and it makes you
feel like you're there will it become
the norm no I can't even fathom how
someone could make a movie like that
I used cuts I use jump cuts and my three
to four minute long videos for God's
sake I admire that nonetheless I
mean Michael Keaton is great because
like I said I feel like he can pull from
his actual life experience this guy he's
trying to battle with himself like
Dumbledore said you do what's right or
do you do what's easy do you try to be
the actor you know you can be or do you
just sell out and just become the
Birdman again this movie is a magnifying
glass over the conflict Oh Hollywood
right now today blockbusters versus
indie movies if you're in a blockbuster
popcorn flick are you an actor are you
just just celebrity but just because
you're in a blockbuster doesn't mean
you're not a good actor and just because
you're in a smaller production doesn't
mean you're a good actor is it was
really it was one of those things Rose
like this is breaking the fourth wall is
just talking to all of us are we gonna
do that you have to have great
characters there's not a character in
this movie I actually didn't like Edward
Norton comes on he's like the pompous
guy he's like Billy Walsh and entourage
but an actor I know the fact they
actually reference real Hollywood
like Robert Downey jr. Iron Man Ryan
Gosling Jeremy Renner Hurt Locker they
referenced things that you actually know
as entertainment as Hollywood movie
makes it feel more real makes you feel
like oh yeah that's in our world and the
movie looking like one shot it makes you
feel like you're actually there and it
makes them feel more real you don't know
it until you see it again like if I had
heard about something like this I'd be
like oh don't feel much different than
the movie it'll just look like it's one
shop you'll see it'll all feel this
stain but it doesn't you actually feel
like you're behind the set like you're
on set at Broadway or hanging out with
these people you're talking to these
people these people feel absurdly real
Michael Keaton in this movie has one of
the greatest monologues to ever
definitely the greatest monologue to a
critic I've ever seen you heard me talk
about critics and I'm like I don't wanna
come to critic this lady is a critic
she's just what I don't like about
critics Michael Keaton's monologue it
was like Church I was like Oh apparently
it's the Sabbath today because this
granted some of the he was raging
about I'm guilty of myself doesn't make
it any less real or relevant and that's
one of the themes of this movie know
what you are except what you are movie
drags on in a bit in the sense that
there was a point in the movie I was
like that movie is gonna end here and I
was like oh no it's gonna end here
alright it's gonna end here three
different endings I feel like if he
ended the movie at the first part that
could have been the ending would've been
fine
second part would have been fine third
part would have been fine but they all
lead to something different
India and Michael Keaton killed it in
this movie Edward Norton was great Emma
Stone killed it everyone was great in
this movie and I felt like I was there I
felt like I was just hanging out with
these people it was unique it was
original it's one of those things where
I'm glad someone made a movie like this
you need a movie like this it's one of
those movies where you can reference go
yeah like Birdman when you watch a movie
after this movie you're gonna notice all
the scene changes and cuts gonna drive
you nuts I will say Birdman is
definitely worth buying on blu-ray so
far right now I believe Birdman is a
limited release I don't know that you've
seen it but if you have seen Birdman
what did you think about it let me
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more